If I were to rank, perhaps the top 20 individuals...
...who helped to shape the world around us,...
...I think Albert Einstein would be on that shortlist.
Kings and queens, they come and go.
Emperors and empresses, well, they leave almost no trace in the footprints of history.
But Albert Einstein's work resonates throughout history even today.
People ask the question, "What has Einstein done for me lately?"
And the answer is, "Everything."
Everything we see around us,...
...the electronics, the satellites, the atom smashers,...
...all of that in some sense, can be traced back to the work of Albert Einstein.
In fact, many of the crumbs, the crumbs from his table,...
...have gone on to win Nobel Prizes for physicists even today.